Welcome back everyone it's Charlie
This will be my new Luke Skywalker
Mandalorian Season 3 Video.
A lot of people are asking
what's going on with him right now
in the timeline, since grogu you left.
So I'll explain because he's
still a really big part of the story.
Jon Favreau, Dave Filoni have teased him
coming back, so we'll break it all down.
If you're brand new to the channel,
I'm doing videos for all the episodes.
Be sure to subscribe to get them,
and I will do Ahsoka episodes
later this year when it premieres too,
because it will continue to the story.
Like they'll have their own story,
but all the shows
in this part of the timeline are called
the Mando verse,
so they're all meant to be connected
and move around the same timeline
with a few exceptions.
Jon Favreau confirmed at the beginning
of The Mandalorian Season
three
that the timeline for each of the seasons
was supposed to move close to real time
the same way things do in the Marvel
movies.
Jon Favreau famously said he's used
his time working on the Marvel movies.
The first two Iron Man movies.
He was also executive producer
on all the Avengers movies through Endgame
that when they created The Mandalorian
and all the spinoff shows,
they call it the Mando verse,
and they base the structure
on the structure
of how the MCU works together.
So each season of The Mandalorian,
the other shows is meant to be
about a year's worth of time.
So in present day of season
three, we're about nine years
after Return of the Jedi Grogu,
who was just with Luke Skywalker
at his Jedi Academy on OS's
for about two years.
And by the end of the Mandalorian Season
three, Grogu will have been away
from Luke Skywalker for about a year,
so not that much time has gone by.
He hasn't been gone from Luke Skywalker
for that long.
Most of what has been happening
on The Mandalorian, with the exception
of going back to course on in
the Core Worlds,
has been happening on this far
right side of the outer rim,
up and down like the Mandalore planet,
The Mandalorian system is way up here
in the upper right
hand corner that's near where accesses
Luke Skywalker's Jedi Academy.
But a lot of the events
of The Mandalorian,
especially the first couple of seasons,
took place
way down here in the bottom right corner.
Like Navarro, tattooing
those planets are down here in the bottom
right hand corner of the galaxy.
We make all the jokes about
how the Armor's new planet is kind of
like the Star Wars
version of Jurassic Park.
There's somewhere
on a version of Jurassic Park
just getting eaten by animals
every single week.
So wherever that planet is,
they'll probably reveal it later.
It's probably somewhere else here
in this part of the outer rim,
like somewhere in the right hand
side of the galaxy.
Originally, Luke Skywalker had planned
for Grogu to become his first new student.
Officially, he did train Leia briefly
before she got pregnant with Ben
Solo, Kylo Ren.
There's no official date on
when that happened, just a date range.
The latest they list is around
11 years after Return of the Jedi.
The way that star Wars records
dates, too, is a little bit different
from the way
Jon Favreau and Dave Filoni talk about it.
If you look up Star Wars dates,
they always list ab
y, which is after the Battle of Yavin,
which is about four years
before Return of the Jedi.
But every time Dave Filoni, Jon Favreau
talk about dates for the band over shows,
they always use Return of the Jedi
as the point of reference.
So for example,
nine years after Return of the Jedi,
The Mandalorian Season three right now
when things are happening,
would be 13 years
after the Battle of Yavin.
So in about two years we'll say
Kylo Ren is born.
So as of right now on
The Mandalorian Season three, while Grogu
is busy becoming a Mandalorian,
getting his pieces of armor,
Luke Skywalker is continuing
to build his Jedi Academy on OS's,
finished physically constructing
the actual buildings themselves
and he started training Leia,
like Leia, has not gotten pregnant yet.
She's about two years out from Kylo Ren,
being born.
They haven't featured her
in The Mandalorian yet,
but we just went to Khorasan again,
which is a huge hub
for the New Republic government.
They revealed
the New Republic seat of government
actually moved to Hosny in prime.
It used to be on Coruscant,
so they haven't completely explained
when that transition happened.
But Mathema became the chancellor
of the New Republic
after they fought out of the rebellion.
Ilia has been her number two,
like she's served
inside the New Republic government
for many years.
At this point, Luke Skywalker has not yet
found any other force
sensitive people to train.
Like I said, he's still training
Leia right now.
Like as we're talking,
once she left training
to give birth to Ben
Solo, that's when he started
finding other children to train.
So by the end of The Mandalorian Season
three, we're still about a year away
from that happening.
The events of the Ahsoka series also just
charting the next part of the timeline
will jump around
a little bit in the timeline,
but the present day of that series
will take place right after the events
of the Mandalorian Season
three, just because of the way
all the handover shows
are meant to move in real time.
The Ahsoka series is unique in the fact
that they're going
to pull a house of the Dragon
where they jump
mid-season in the timeline,
so there'll be a little bit of that
takes place around Return of the Jedi.
Then they'll jump forward into present day
grand.
Admiral
Thrawn will be the main villain on Ahsoka.
He's supposed to be the major crossover
villain for all the mando over
shows eventually.
So he's like the Thanos of the mando verse
at this point of the Star Wars timeline.
So that's why they're slowly
teasing him out on the Mandalorian.
They've been mentioning him
a couple of times.
We'll see more Easter eggs for him
during the Mandalorian Season
three, and eventually
he'll show up on the Ahsoka series
at the end of the book of Boba Fett,
we saw Ahsoka had spent some time
with Luke Skywalker and Grogu,
who had his Jedi Academy.
She wasn't there for all two years.
That Grogu who was there,
she just visited.
She'd been on that mission to find Grant,
Admiral Thrawn and Ezra Bridger
for the past few years.
That's what she'd been doing when we saw
her during the Mandalorian Season two,
tracking down Morgan Elsbeth,
the agent of Thrawn.
She was looking for more information
about his whereabouts,
and that had been happening
since the end of Return of the Jedi.
Since this moment
here, we'll see a version of this
in a live action,
like when I say Ahsoka is going
to pull the house of the Dragon
and jump in the timeline
at the beginning of the show,
I believe we're going to see a version
of this scene in live action.
So when we saw her during season
two of The Mandalorian, she'd
been looking for Thrawn and Ezra Bridger
for almost six years.
During this time, she briefly visits
Luke Skywalker and Grogan
just to check up on them.
The reason why she told Mando that
she couldn't be the one to train Grogu
you either, like
why she pushed him towards Luke Skywalker
is because of the trauma of what happened
with an infant Skywalker in his fall
to the dark side becoming Darth Vader.
She had so much PTSD
that she hadn't fully gotten over yet
that she wasn't willing to take a chance
that that could happen again with Grogu,
who they got into this
during the Mandalorian season two,
where she talked about
sensing the same fear, the same vibe
coming from Grogu that Yoda Obi-Wan Kenobi
Quigg on Jane, the other Jedi master sense
coming from Young and again Skywalker.
So if there could have been a 1% chance
that the same fate could befall Grogu,
she didn't want to take it.
A soldier will continue to deal with her
PTSD and again, Skywalker feelings
during the Ahsoka series.
Hayden Christensen is supposed to cameo
in some way.
They didn't say exactly how.
So I'm assuming it's either
a force goes in again in present day
or a flashback to the Clone Wars
or a flashback of them facing each other
when he becomes Darth Vader.
Maybe if we're lucky, we'll get all three.
That would be really cool.
But when she visited Luke
Skywalker and Grogu, who she told Luke
about her mission to find grand
Admiral Thrawn in Ezra Bridger.
So now in present day, Luke knows about
all the stuff that she's dealing with.
He knows about Thrawn,
he knows about Ezra Bridger.
She leaves him saying,
May the force be with you
and telling him that
perhaps they'll see each other again.
Will I see you again?
Perhaps
that's meant to mean
that they will definitely see each other
like they were very on the nose
about like,
Oh yeah, we're definitely going
to bring Luke Skywalker back.
They want to set up further cameo scenes
like we saw during the book of Boba Fett.
And here's where we get to our major
Thrawn crossover,
where Luke Skywalker gets involved
with the big battle
against Thrawn in the endgame
for all these Mando over shows.
Luke is a big part of this,
but for obvious reasons
they want to spend most of their time
on all the shows developing Roku, Mando,
the Mandalorians in general as the people
Ahsoka, the crew of the Ghost,
any other new characters they introduce
like the skeleton crew characters.
They don't want to keep going back
to Luke Leia, the legacy characters
every 5 seconds.
Like we don't want to keep going back
to tattooing,
but all those characters
are still really important to the events
that are happening in the galaxy
right now,
so they'll continue to be a part of them
when it makes sense.
That's the way that Dave
Filoni talks about.
Like, does it make sense
for this character to show up here?
The reason Luke didn't know about Grand
Admiral Thrawn before Ahsoka tells him
everything is because for all of Luke's
existence is a core part of the rebellion
against the Empire.
Everything that's happened to him
since the New Hope Grand Admiral Thrawn
has been lost in the unknown regions
in most of his colleagues in the Empire.
His fellow officers
had even written him off as dead.
Most assumed he'd never return.
They just forgot about him.
So when Luke comes along in a New Hope,
joins the rebellion with Obi-Wan
Kenobi is push.
Nobody is talking about Thrawn,
even the Empire.
Luke never learns about him.
In fact,
most of the other Imperial officers
hated Thrawn so much
because he was better than them.
The Emperor showed him so much favoritism.
Even Darth Vader hated Thrawn
and was happy to see him disappear
like one less person
to challenge me for my supremacy.
But now that Ahsoka has learned
Thrawn has returned,
the threat of the Seventh Fleet is back.
The empires were surging,
trying to reform in the outer rim.
She's told Luke about this and
he's at least aware of what's going on.
Thrawn would want to get rid
of Luke Skywalker's Jedi Academy,
but the location of the academy on Aziz
was a big secret that Luke kept from
almost everyone except Leia. Ahsoka.
Now Mando, only a small
handful of people know how to find it.
It doesn't appear
on a lot of the newer maps,
but it's on all the Knights
of the Old Republic maps.
The planet is right
above Antalya on the upper right hand
portion of the outer rim near Luthor,
where Ezra Bridger is from, not too far
from Mandalore, where we just were.
So it's very far away from the core worlds
where most everyone's
attention in the galaxy is on.
Usually you go to the outer
rim to hide out.
In Thrawn, for example, was lost
in the unknown regions
on the complete other side of the galaxy.
So that's the other big reason
Luke Skywalker wouldn't be super
worried about Thrawn. Like,
okay, that's dangerous.
We should deal with that at some point.
But he's on the other side of the galaxy
about as far away you could get
from Luke Skywalker's academy
as you could possibly get.
So Luke is thinking we'll deal with this,
but eventually
and at this point,
the last couple of years,
it seems like Ahsoka
has just learned that Thrawn has returned
through Morgan Elsbeth
and she's trying to prevent him
from marshaling the rest of his forces
in that turning
into a much bigger problem.
But it's still meant
to be very early days for that.
And while we've been watching
the first couple of seasons
of The Mandalorian,
Thrawn has been pulling strings from afar,
influencing the remnants of the Empire
along with Moff Gideon.
The two of them aren't friends
or anything like that.
They don't particularly like each other.
It's more of a mutual arrangement.
We're on the same team kind of thing.
They both want
the empire to take over again,
but each for their own different reasons.
Moff Gideon wants to help the Emperor
return.
That's part of the whole cloning subplot.
Like another wrinkle in that Thrawn
secretly hated the Emperor and is glad
he's gone.
He only wants the Empire to return
so he can control it the way he thinks.
The galaxy should be run
all to the benefit of his own people.
The kiss,
his ultimate loyalty is to the ships race.
Everything he's doing with the Empire.
His whole time since the beginning,
after Revenge of the Sith
has been to protect his people.
So eventually, once
he does return in force and starts
taking over portions of the galaxy again,
all the characters
start fighting him in a bigger way.
We'll probably see early theory
Luke Skywalker returning,
fighting with Ahsoka, teaming up
with Ezra Bridger to being Grogu
everyone who's for Sensitive or a Jedi,
and we'll see some really cool
lightsaber battles,
like a version of what we saw
at the end of the Clone Wars
with the Battle of Mandalore with them all
teaming up.
Picture a live action version of this.
So that's basically
what's going on with Luke Skywalker.
Their general plans for him in this part
of the timeline the next couple of years.
For those of you
that also really like
this part of the timeline,
the way that Jon Favreau, Dave
Filoni are dealing with the Mandalorians
and what's happening in Star Wars,
this whole heir to the empire
they're doing in live action,
the way Jon Favreau talks about it, too,
this could continue
for several more years,
like they'll just continue
making more seasons of The Mandalorian.
These are the spinoff shows
for as long as people
will continue watching them like there's
no hard out date that they have,
they could wind up making ten seasons of
People continue liking it.
So let me know when you want Luke
Skywalker to cameo next.
Do you want him to cameo
on the Ahsoka series later this year,
or do you want them to save him
for a little bit later
when they all team up again?
My Full Mandalorian Season
3 Episode 5 Video We'll post next.
You can click here to watch that all.
Update the link
as soon as I post that and click here
for all my other Mandalorian episodes.
Thank you so much for watching.
Everyone stay safe.
This is the way.